non c'est surtout à toi de te demander
pourquoi bah tu n'y as pas les rares
ballons au [ __ ] si tu as fait un peu
froid non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce que vous êtes déjà réveillé en
ayant tout oublié de votre soirée de la
veille
ah non ben non non non alors à temps
est ce que vous vous êtes déjà réveillé
en ayant tout oublié de votre soirée de
la veille
oui voilà ça arrive même aux meilleurs
et en général quand ça arrive on n'est
pas bien et pas seulement parce qu'on a
l'impression d'avoir un animal mort dans
le fond de la gorge
essayer d'avoir les neurones qu'il faut
un wolof d'être dans le vrai problème
c'est que un c'est angoissant cette
impression qui nous manque un bout de
notre vie est deux on a peur d'avoir
fait n'importe quoi alors en général
dans ces cas là la première chose qu'on
fait c'est d'appeler ses potes pour qui
nous rassure ce qu'ils font rarement
alors soit parce que on a effectivement
fait n'importe quoi ou soit parce que on
a des potes un peu taquin mais est ce
que vous vous êtes déjà demandé pourquoi
on perd la mémoire dans ces cas là
pourquoi sur le moment notre cerveau il
est assez fonctionnel pour nous
permettre de parler de marché de bouger
de façon de plus ou moins digne mais
quand même
mais il n'est pas suffisamment
fonctionnel pour qu'on se rappelle de
tout ça le lendemain alors déjà il ya
deux types de black out ou amnésie
lacunaire le black out total
on se rappelle de rien sur une période
donnée et c'est définitif et le black
out partiel
on a oublié quelques passages de la
soirée du coup parfois on n'a même pas
conscience mais ça peut nous revenir
soit quand on nous les raconte soit si
on voit aussi on entend quelque chose
qui faire remonter le souvenir du front
de sa cuve de gnôle ensuite le black out
ça arrive toujours quand deux critères
sont réunis d'abord quand on a vu des
quantités d'alcool disons nous c'est
quand et que le taux d'alcool a augmenté
de façon très rapide dans le sang c'est
ce qui arrive quand on boit beaucoup
d'alcool en peu de temps mais aussi
quand on voit sans avoir mangé avant
l'alcool est absorbé à 20% dans
l'estomac et à 80% un tout petit peu
plus loin dans l'intestin grêle
quand il arrive dans un estomac vide il
est assimilé beaucoup plus rapidement il
se trouve qu'il y en a un qui aime pas
du tout ça pour l'alcoolémie grimpe trop
vite c'est l'hippocampe passage
rochât francs alors non on ne compte pas
le petit poney aquatique il pas contre
la partie du cerveau qui joue un rôle
hyper important dans la mémoire la
mémoire c'est un truc compliqué il ya
plusieurs types de mémoire qui ont
chacun leurs propres réseaux leurs
propres réseaux de neurones 1 alors ils
communiquent entre eux mais ils ont
chacun leur propre job en gros coder les
infos et les stocker plus ou moins
longtemps pour qu'on puisse les
récupérer plus tard sous forme de
souvenirs
il ya la mémoire à court terme qu'on
appelle aussi la mémoire de travail et
qui permet de se souvenir d'informations
utiles à ce qu'on est en train de faire
là maintenant genre où est-ce qu'on a
posé notre verre quand on fait un black
out c'est pas tellement cette forme de
mémoire là qui est perturbé encore que
des fois on se rappelle plus on a posé
son verre c'est plutôt une des formes de
la mémoire à long terme qui morfle c'est
la mémoire épisodique
celle qui permet de se souvenir des
événements qu'on a vécu ou caen avec qui
est ce qu'on a ressenti en les vivant
alors avec le temps on perd ces détails
mais le lendemain normalement on est
censé son souvenir
sauf que là sauf que là non justement
parce que on à l'hippocampe qui fait des
saltos s'est pas vraiment des saltos
mais disons qu'il n'arrive pas à
travailler comme d'habitude parce que
pour stocker les infos il fait circuler
les données grâce à un réseau de
neurones spécifiques qui communiquent
entre notamment grâce pour glutamate pas
le glutamate de sodium qu'on met dans le
boeuf aux oignons le glutamate un
neurotransmetteur quand l'alcool
augmente massivement dans le sang les
molécules d'éthanol elle perturbe les
récepteurs sur lesquels normalement se
fixe le glutamate et elle favorise
l'action d'un autre neurotransmetteur
qui a une fonction principalement
inhibitrice c'est à dire de ralentir le
jeu et qu'on appelle le gaba là on est
en train de danser sur du sean paul nue
sur une table tu notes et tu transmets
aux stocks
[ __ ] j'ai plus de but à matt tu tu dis
quoi
donc les infos elle circule plus
correctement et elle n'arrive pas
jusqu'à l'entrepôt de stockage et le
lendemain on se souvient plus de rien
alors bon qui est pénible mais en soi ce
n'est pas très dangereux pour votre
santé par contre quand vous êtes dans
cet état là pouvait très bien commettre
ou subir des trucs grave genre des
agressions des blessures etc sans vous
en rappeler le lendemain d'autant plus
que quand on est dans cet état là notre
capacité à prendre les bonnes décisions
elle est sévèrement diminuée et l'autre
problème c'est que si on se met à boire
de façon un peu moins occasionnels voir
de façon régulière
ça peut avoir des effets durables sur la
mémoire à court terme et à long terme il
ya le syndrome de korsakoff par exemple
qu'on connaît bien et dans lequel en
plus des troubles de la mémoire il ya
des troubles de l'humeur des troubles du
comportement et des difficultés à se
repérer dans le temps et dans l'espace
l'alcool peut aussi finir par détruire
des neurones et créer des troubles
neurologiques physique durable voire
définitif
donc si vous avez régulièrement des
black out c'est l'occasion de se poser
des questions sur votre consommation
d'alcool et éventuellement si vous avez
besoin faites vous aider pour diminuer
voire pour arrêter globalement
d'ailleurs si vous buvez régulièrement
pas la peine d'avoir des black out pour
se poser des questions sur votre
consommation d'alcool
je voulais un test que vous pouvez faire
pour voir un petit peu où vous en êtes
dans la barre d'infos et si vous avez
envie qu'on prend le tout ça dans une
prochaine vidéo n'hésitez pas à me le
dire dans les commentaires
voilà détester c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien mais pas trop et pas
trop souvent
et puis surtout portez vous bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]